One idea that's very common in our
culture is that poverty is caused by
lack of money and that's a really stupid
idea because money is very difficult to
handle.
I had clients who were drug addicts and
the worst possible thing that could
happen to them was that they got some
money.
They're just done.
First of all,
you know,
they were hanging around with people who
were little on the sociopathic side and
so especially if they weren't that
bright and couldn't defend themselves
very well,
as soon as they got money while it was
off to the bar with all the friends and
you know,
one guy I remember in particular,
every time he got as his disability
check,
he was gone for five days,
usually fundament a ditch,
you know,
because you just go to the bar,
spent every Saturday had on alcohol and
cocaine and wake up in a ditch.
Three quarters dead,
uh,
eventually completely dead.
And No.
Then he was ashamed and horrified and
repentant and he'd straightened himself
out again.
And then that was all well and good
until,
as long as he was broke until the next
check showed up and then bang the same
thing.
So you know,
it's not like money is necessarily a
good for everyone.
It's hard manage money.
It's really easy for it to disappear.
I mean elderly people have a hell of a
time now because you know,
crooks are contacting them on the
Internet nonstop.
And so just giving people money,
money's like,
it's like pouring water in their hands.
It's not that helpful.
Not necessarily that helpful.
And then of course contributors to
poverty are well,
it's not so good to have a low Iq.
You know,
people don't like the idea of Iq because
it seems so arbitrary,
you know,
have a high Iq.
Well it's not like you deserved it.
Exactly.
It's your setup that way pretty much
right from the beginning.
It's a very,
very,
very stable.
You can make a high Iq person stupider
by not educating them up to the level of
their possibility,
but taking someone who has a low Iq and
trying to raise that.
It's like if you can figure out how to
do that,
well you know it's Nobel prize time for
you because people have tried that a lot
and most recently with those,
you know,
Luminol lumosity games and that sort of
thing and the evidence that those
produce anything other than brilliant
performances on the lumosity game itself
is basically zero.
We haven't been able to figure out how
to see cause I intelligence is a cross
domain phenomena and you can get really
good in a single domain by practicing
like Matt and what you'd want is to
practice like matt in a single domain
and hope that it generalizes to other
domains.
That's the holy grail of intelligence
and creeks.
It's like,
no,
no one's done it.
People claim it,
but the claims never hold up and people
have been trying for a long time to do
it and they haven't been able to do it.
And
differences in Iq really make a
difference.
You know,
I mean you guys,
average Iq is probably one slash 25
slash 30 ad at 1:15.
You're at the 85th percentile and 1:15
would barely get you going for you.
For Harvard University,
1:30,
you're probably graduate school material
1:45.
You're up there at the range where you
can probably do pretty much whatever you
want.
Although as you get smarter,
the scatter between your abilities
increase.
So you might have a very high verbal Iq
but not be so good at mathematics or the
other way around.
But it's a massive contributor to
lifetime success and I don't know what
to do about that.
I mean why do smart people make more
money?
Well,
they get to where the edge of production
is faster.
So if you have a thousand people and you
rank order them by ICU,
the smart people are going to come up
with new ideas first and they're going
to have more ideas and they're going to
strategize better.
And you know,
with an Iq of 90,
which is 15 percent of the population,
you think about that 15 percent of the
population.
That's pretty much the threshold for
reading instructions and being able to
follow them.
So you know,
and our society is increasingly
sophisticated,
so it's by no means obvious,
you know,
the Liberals think well society is
unfair because there's unemployment and
the Conservatives think while there's a
job for everyone and,
but none of them think,
well,
there are massive,
massive,
massive differences in people's ability
far greater than anyone realizes.
And that poses a structural problem.
I had a client and I got him a volunteer
job,
which is way harder than you think.
You need a police check,
for example,
like it's harder to get a volunteer job
than a real job.
But I regard them in a volunteer job and
he had to fold pieces of paper letters
was he worked at a charity.
He had to follow up pieces of paper in
three so that he could put them inside
envelopes and,
and then the letters which were in a
pile had to be matched with the proper
envelopes,
which we're also in a pile,
but some of them were French and some of
the wrangling.
So the French ones had to be matched
carefully to the French envelopes.
And then if,
you know,
if there was one envelope out of,
out of order,
well then he had to figure out whether
it was the papers that were out of order
or the letters that were out of order.
And then some of the letters had
photographs attached them and you
weren't supposed to bend the photographs
and,
but they weren't always in the same
place.
So that meant you had to figure out how
to fold the paper in three a bunch of
different ways without creasing the
photograph.
And then the other thing is,
and I never realized how difficult it is
to put a piece of paper in an envelope
until I watched someone who couldn't do
it and he probably had an Iq of about
80,
you know,
if you met him on the street,
you wouldn't think anything different of
him.
He was normal looking guy had some other
problems.
Um,
I trained him to fold those damn papers
for like 30 hours and he got reasonably
good at it.
But you know,
if you're good at it and you probably
all are,
you fold it and the edges line up
exactly like really,
exactly.
The tolerance is probably half a
millimeter or something like that.
Then you do the second fold and the
tolerance is the same.
But let's imagine that the first full
you,
you're out by an eighth of an inch in
the second full year out by an eighth of
an inch.
So it's a little crooked.
Not means in totally route by a quarter
of an inch.
Then it won't fit in the damn envelope.
So then you kind of crumpled envelope
when you put it in there and then it
gets stuck in the sorting machine.
And so he sweated blood trying to do
that job and eventually big eventually
plan to fire him.
So imagine what that's like,
hey,
you know you can't get a job.
And then so you get a job at a charity
as a volunteer and a charity decides to
fire you.
You know?
I mean really that's just.
So I talked to the woman who was running
it and suggested that that might be a
little on the devastating side.
I mean,
she had her reasons,
you know,
he,
he was always asking people questions
about how to do his job and you know,
so that meant he was interfering with
the productivity of other people and it
was genuine interference.
I mean,
she wasn't being mean and it was her job
to make sure the place did what it was
supposed to.
So,
you know,
she was between a rock and a hard place.
Um,
he eventually decided that the job
wasn't for him and relatively soon after
that I think it was too stressful and
uh,
he quit.
So that solved that problem except then
you didn't have job,
which of course is a problem.
Um,
it has a happy ending.
This story,
as far as I know,
he,
he got a dog because he was very
lonesome.
And that dog man,
having that guy trained,
that dog,
that was something else,
that dog just think he lost 30 pounds
while he was training that dog because
dogs,
they're,
you know,
dominant.
And he had to have a tussle with the dog
to figure out who was in charge and it's
a lot of responsibility to have a dog,
but he was pretty damn committed to that
dog.
And he managed it.
The things he went through to keep that
dog.
You just cannot possibly imagine.
It's like a,
it's like a,
it's like a surreal.
It was surreal.
Just like the nuclear missile silo.
I mean,
he had people following him around
informing on him because they thought he
was abusing the dog when in fact,
because I watched the dog was clearly
abusive.
Um,
so he got a job helping a woman who
trained dogs and,
and then he had a job.
So Hooray,
you know,
but it was like a miracle fundamentally.
So anyways,
the reason I'm telling you all this is
because there was a reason for the Cold
War and the reason was that there is
inequality and there's different
theories about how to address that
inequality and different theories about
why it exists.
And there was a Marxist theory about why
it exists,
which was roughly something like
property equals theft.
And those who have more have taken it
from those who have less,
which seems to me to eliminate any
conceptual lization that there isn't a
fixed pot of money,
you know,
money expands actually as we become more
technologically proficient.
And lots of people who have money have
it because they've generated a lot of
wealth.
I mean,
Bill Gates is a great example of that,
right?
He popularized computing,
he made it possible for everybody to
have access to computing.
It's like,
seems like a good good for him.
You know.
And you could say the same thing about
Steve jobs and maybe you'll be able to
say the same thing about Elon Musk and
you know,
these guys have tremendous resources at
their disposal,
but you know,
they're not like,
they're not bathing in bank notes.
You know,
they're,
you're trying to continue to do things
and they use their money to do things.
And.